[Music]
Lavar you need to have a CG animated
movie about always written by next week
oh man how am I gonna make a movie about
talking toys any good
[Music]
I've got it
[Applause]
no commercial work back tomorrow water
buddy how am I gonna make a giant hand
for building blocks good
[Music]
movie written by the end of the day
it's Angry Birds
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to who
says there can't be good video game
movies goddamn Angry Birds does based on
the hick game from 2009 Angry Birds was
a phenomenon that practically took over
the world
everybody loved its simple premise easy
gameplay and quirky style
so of course Sony leapt at the
opportunity to make a film at the height
of its popularity nine years later yeah
nine years what two of them so long were
they actually waiting for this to get
nostalgic to cash in on it or hey maybe
they just really wanted to get it right
before unleashing their cinematic opus
well judging by what we got
Angry Birds probably spend as much time
on its story as well
Angry Birds it's remarkably lazy in so
many ways but apparently was still a big
hit
even warranting a friggin sequel why
because to quote friedrich nietzsche god
is dead and you killed him with Angry
Birds we never knew what he meant by
that last part but now we do despite it
making a ton of cash there are so many
critics and audience members that just
hated this movie ever since it was
announced I have people asking me to
review it and ever since it came out I
had even more people asking me to review
it sadly it's both popular enough and
bad enough to warrant attention let's
take a look at what these bird brains
came up with this is Angry Birds the
movie so we start off this barrel of
fresh ideas with the incredibly original
opening of somebody running late well if
this fresh new idea worked in Back to
the Future Green Lantern lilo and Stitch
girl who left through time big fat liar
Buffy the Vampire Slayer Alice in
Wonderland Tommy Boy can't return Spider
Man to Brazil for what exam funeral
gremlins Mulan and an animate trope so
well know there's countless images of
people running late with toast in their
mouths why not one more this is red
played by Jason Sudeikis who's on his
way to be a clown and a birthday party
like I said he arrives late or does he
I'm not late look at the time see the
order set before noon the party so wait
they said arrive before noon it's noon
and the party's over look at the
straight
oh wait I'm sorry these are the studio
notes don't I tried to keep my body
between the ground in the box but no I
think I got a little bruised see
anything back there hmm
don't know which one of these to go with
why not both red finally loses his
temper and smashes the cake into the
parents face gluten-free cake what the
heck is wooden I mean does gluten even
exist
what buddy slips on a squirrel
destroying the egg behind him
congratulations it's a boy
[Music]
um did we just witness a murder
what's his clown name pigeon white as
the credits roll we see red has some
anger issues as it confusingly cuts back
and forth between him being a child and
him being an adult with literally no
segue or reason I didn't even notice it
the first time I know that doesn't sound
like much but it's not like it's showing
him growing up establishing who he is it
just kind of randomly cuts to him as a
kid we just cut to him as an adult then
a kid then an adult then him being born
here in fact the whole intro seems out
of sequence it says the title then it
says the studio's present then it cuts
two random points in his life in no
particular order
like I said ending with him being born
and then it cuts back to him with the
family he visited absolutely none of it
ties together
it's literally random scenes in random
order it makes no sense and that was my
review of Angry Birds oh I'm sorry did
my sloppy half-ass editing confuse you
well if someone can make 352 million
dollars off of it I might as well as
point of what skipping the tough parts
to the parents take red to trial because
he was the first thing their child saw
being hatched oh by the way you want to
hear the weak-ass reason why they use
slingshots in this movie instead of just
flying
why don't birds fly I'm gonna tell you
what where else would we ever want to go
not a good joke one of the many lines I
don't think was in the script and was
just the actors talking without knowing
the microphone was on this terrifying
star of your nightmares tonight as a
judge that sentence is read to anger
management but read reveals the judge is
just two birds to make him seem taller
what does this have to do with anything
going on even with the judge ignoring
that review mr. riah given the severity
of the crimes what the might art oh my
god we set him up for about two second
so this punchline really pays off hey
compared to the time they put in for the
other jokes two seconds is long anger
management class
I plucked my life he means the f-word
kids nope oh I just let that pause
because I know you're laughing so hard
at the idea of a bird not giving another
bird a hug what you're not laughing Abed
well you should it's repeated all
throughout the movie I don't even think
I've really understood it the first time
but the movie is tiny it's funny over
and over so I should leave the
appropriate amount of space for laughter
is it too late to get that creepy girl
from hereditary in this man it's been a
while since something I'm funny happened
actually no it hasn't but here's another
one anyway he's attacking a sign he
doesn't like I guess this could be
humorous if anybody acted like they
cared about anything that's probably the
biggest problem I get throughout this
entire film look at this slapstick
there's energy but no creativity to it
look at these expressions they're big
but nothing clever is being done with
them heron pigeon even the performances
particularly from our lead all sound
like they just took the first take and
never asked for another it sounds
unbelievably like autopilot okay I guess
that's art that's garbage and that's
exotic everybody feels like they're just
doing the bare minimum sometimes not
even that my Rudolf placed the same
smiling weirdo she always does Josh GAD
plays the same hyper dummy he always
does and I don't really remember what
character Danny McBride usually has
which is fitting because I don't really
remember what character he's supposed to
have here either I guess he just blows
we doing down there exactly what you
think I'm doing down here believe it or
not there is an actual funny moment when
they reveal why everybody is there at
anger management and one of them is so
bad they can't even say it out loud
[Music]
Tarrance seems to have had an incident
we never find out what he did it's left
entirely to the imagination and what
makes this even funnier Sean Penn plays
this part and what makes this even
funnier is he never says a word he just
groans how the hell did we get a joke
that works on three different levels in
a movie where the jokes don't even work
on one level what's that just a day
we're really good writers were brought
in for like two seconds okay you're the
finest writers in Hollywood we need some
really good jokes for a movie oh we
already wrote one while you were talking
oh I guess that's why you're the best in
town what is this movie called by the
way Angry Bird you're already gone
aren't you yeah well at least we got one
joke out of it mmm back to our usual
writer
[Music]
it's a pleasure watching work then these
a Mexican food to do the sequel
tell us your story bomb well sometimes
when I get upset I literally blow up
okay I explode like a bomb yeah remember
that level in Angry Birds where they
just sat around and did therapy they
were trying new ideas like what Mario
did in fact that might actually be a
Mario game dude no can do
I just went boom boom before class the
other birds want to hang out with red
but he gives them the cold shoulder um
busy too you're not good at this buddy
it's charming up to a point and now it's
just sad again I'm pretty sure he was
just talking about the script let's do
that incredible hug joke again no means
no you know there's running jokes and
then there's yeah I'm definitely gonna
be there for the marathon yeah I'm
definitely gonna train so hard yeah I'm
definitely gonna show my support yeah
I'm definitely gonna be there l just
donate to the cause jokes give him
credit at least this random cut to his
childhood includes bad exposition once
my Diego gonna come back your parents
ever tell you Mighty Eagle isn't real he
doesn't have parents they were killed in
the great Disney genocide of dramatic
convenience but troubles and the literal
horizon as a ship full of pigs arrives
destroying Reds house well more damages
the side of it because destroying the
whole thing would be funnier and Flor
knows we can't have that in the movie
Green's we saw your Island across the
sea and we thought wonder what they're
up to these things look like the minions
banged whatever animal died to give us
green eggs and ham except we had the
luxury event meat being dead there's no
other place besides here we call it oh
you know this movie would be half a
length if they didn't keep repeating the
same goddamn jokes what did you run out
the bad hugging joke huh no you still
slipped in that gym again
oh that relatable nobody wants to hug me
humor in the industry we call that the
Iggy Pop the birds welcome the pigs but
red doesn't trust them because they
destroyed his house at least that's how
it's supposed to come across but
honestly it sounds more like he has some
deep-seated racism with other cultures
they don't
our king sends his warmest regards him
out of the friendship between the pigs
and the bird star who cares they destroy
more of the stuff we worked hard to
build have you got the night off why'd
you fix my house
what's a religion better not be
different from ours everyone knows
there's just one gotcha man your friends
the pigs proudly give you the slingshot
we present to you a flimsy pretext to
make a game not meant to be a movie
seemed like it was meant to be a movie
don't worry by the end you'll all see
this as a weapon of mass destruction
so let's sneak sin to the pigs boat and
finds little green men from Toy Story by
the way why do I get the feeling this
book and the pigs boat is just a
variation of this I snuck on to their
boat he confronts the pigs about their
being even more of them as well as the
strange devices he doesn't recognize any
questions nobody needs that in their
lives my cousins are simple folk watch
ABC nothing see nothing you could
literally put anything there and it
would have gotten the laugh but you
decided to go with nothing so you get
nothing literally any joke could have
worked there watch ABC for ABC cabbage
ABC Johnson okay maybe not any joke
the waiter says his cousin's weren't
smart so he wanted to be sure it was a
safe place before he revealed them the
birds believe him and everybody
celebrates with not the worst pink jokes
ever written but but the helmet
comparing it to yeah these are the worst
pick jokes ever written
it was P Glenn piggyback rides somebody
needs to be punished and with sharp
things
speaking of pig puns I think I can come
up with a few more after this
disturbingly confusing subtext children
are born you guys don't like hey wish we
did
Shanthi yeah how about bigger file
bigger ass better ham bacon generate hog
deviant Stein offender I could think of
more but I don't want to think of this
in general the bigs are actually
intending to eat them but nobody seems
to catch on to that except for red who
everybody continues to mock you the tool
that well if you're me dummy whoa
I mean wow I couldn't write a line like
that I mean that's ingenious
I want to take him to put that together
what that's like the greatest insult
sense much other bucks you fart ghost
Abdal wrinkles I think we found your
replacement
[Applause]
[Music]
some Rick gets an idea to find Mighty
Eagle so he can stop the pigs evil plan
right before confusing out of nowhere
fantasy the other birds have about him
um Josh GAD and if I say this but you're
really getting typecast as kids films
characters who need to come out of the
closet while climbing mountains
imagining what the Eagles battle cry is
like they thankfully cast aside the
obnoxious annoying writing and just dive
directly into obnoxious annoying sounds
what would a Mighty Eagle battle cry
sound like torture your intellect when
your ear bleeding is more than enough
[Applause]
you pay to see this folks could have
used that money to buy a collection of
barn animals barking themselves to death
but instead you went for this to the
credit both of these are very similar
but there's some joy to this they get to
where the Eagle lives and they decide to
swim in his pool and again we partake in
a fascinating Lee botched joke two of
them take a long time swimming in the
pool in slow-mo only to have the Eagle
come out and take his daily piss in it
okay so bad enough they hold
uncomfortably long on this piste taking
only geniuses steal from norm of the
north but if this joke was gonna work
and that's a big goddamn if they should
have shown them in the pool while he was
pissing and read tries to warn them
about what's going on
then the slow-mo would make sense we
would want it to go slower to soak up so
to speak the humor of the situation here
it's just slow-mo for no reason dragging
out what isn't set up properly yet again
every joke seems weirdly backwards I
keep expecting to see one of them in a
flower shop saying that's me but that
couldn't happen because that film
actually made me laugh the Eagle voice
by Peter Dinklage spots the birds and
chats with them you have drank my piss
it's a weird test so they go inside his
cave and find a warped mirror hey hey
they look like the game that'd be funny
if they didn't already do that throw
them the pile of other shitty repeated
jokes but if repetition to the points of
decapitation is your game don't worry
they give themselves a dance party
the fourth one in this movie so far yeah
you know how most animated films
nowadays end with a dance party to sell
a soundtrack they made a whole goddamn
movie about it okay okay maybe I'm
jumping the gun just because you have
for dance party sequences in your movie
doesn't necessarily mean it's lame or
manipulative five on the other hand oh
yeah right after they find out the
Eagles too lazy to help him they go back
to interrupt another dance party going
on dancing has much dancing in it and
ironically feel dirty watching it so the
pigs take all the eggs while distracting
them with their fifth dance party and
sail back to their Island so read
through shitty writing and unfunny jokes
perfectly white break the norm here
tries to inspire everybody to go after
him they stole our kids I mean who does
that have you ever stolen anyone's
children have you
I mean you look like you would you know
this funny gags already not funny don't
maybe think about seeing him on To Catch
a Predator so they build a ship to chase
after the pigs who are back on their
Island celebrating
nobody because it's not clever or funny
or worth mentioning did anybody turn in
a second draft the birds get to the
island and try to figure out a way to
attack and you can all guess where this
is going
oh Jesus that'd be awesome now they
start launching themselves like in the
game honey they took a long time
establishing the bomber's ability to
blow up and even create a character arc
for him well the first time we find out
about this birds weird power is wow
about that my teacher can shoot
fireballs out of her butt how's that
song go from the rankin/bass version of
Return of the King it's so easy not to
try that not make it out to the
soundtrack well I guess it's a little
less obvious than hog topic let's just
agree though everybody's in pain somehow
gee I wonder if the mimes gonna say oh
my god it's like they say if at first
you don't succeed that body read Chuck
and bomb make it into the castle where
they come across never mind people that
happened we let it happen we must never
let it happen again join me in thinking
of ways of preventing that from
happening in the future
Chuck rips off the Quicksilver scene
from x-men that x-men would later rip
off themselves themselves as they get
closer to the eggs everyone fights in a
climax that is so desperate and so
banking on your kids low attention span
that it's actually hard to find a shot
that is over two seconds long I you
not watch these scenes uncut and see if
any of them hold on a shot for more than
two seconds
the whole climax is like this folks
freaking scary Christ fast editing is
fine but you need a variety to care look
at two towers it had fast editing but it
also knew to give sweeping shots and
moments focusing on characters taking in
what's going on because they like you
audience and they want to give you
something good this clearly just wants
to wave its keys at the low attention
span it thinks you have and wants to
encourage you to keep I think this feels
actually worse than binge drinking
because you lose more brain cells and
vomit at a greater level so the ego
comes in to save the eggs leaving it to
read and King pig to fight this is
dynamite it's so easy not to try but he
have smarts the pig blowing up the
kingdom as everyone gets their seemingly
smaller pile of eggs back Jesus was a
lot bigger before
Angry Birds got dark one family seems to
be missing theirs though but rad comes
in with the final one I think these
belong to you oh oh we can only afford
to raise two we'll have to eat one of
them oh look he's blushing I'm not
blushing I'm just red
[Applause]
that was the big cheering and laughing
line feel like you could have put pretty
much anything there where corporate
shills in Hollywood's playground hi
bethie emoji movie is looking pretty
good right now
[Applause]
let's see if this ever got funny Wow
it's not quite the genius of King Koopa
ordering a pizza but it's still
disappoints red makes it look like he
still doesn't want to hang out with
Chuck and bomb but tells them he was
just kidding guys I'm just messing with
you
get in here I can't end this movie
without sharing the blame with others
she's with all the dance party sequences
and surprised it didn't end on what I
here we go well trust me I Will Survive
is the perfect musical choice for this
film this was unbearable it it doesn't
even feel done a lot of bad comedies
just tell jokes that don't work this
just tells sentences that don't work
it's hard to remember in recent memory
of film this lazily written lazily acted
and lazily directed nothing feels unique
nothing feels passionate nothing feels
earned it comes across as rushed awkward
and just not caring I mean I know every
movie takes a lot of time and effort to
make which is why it's a shame when a
film is so bad none of that comes across
I'm sure a lot of work and time did go
into making this but it never comes
across in the viewing experience it just
feels like one long incredibly
unentertaining commercial if you want to
play the games that makes sense
help mostly you'll probably playing the
game while watching this damn movie but
if you want to check out this obnoxious
piece of Burchett on its own I say fly
away as fast as possible I'm the
Nostalgia Critic and you know where's a
muse when you need one
back from the dead to inspire a little
oh good I was just talking about the
Angry Birds movie I should have
remembered this so she didn't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
poop I sound God to him in Spanish
[Music]
you
Wow about that my teacher can shoot
fireballs out of her butt
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out now I'm not repeating the same
charity uh but this charity does also
have a connection to Red Nose Day it is
comic relief both comic relief USA and
their sister organization comic relief a
UK share a vision of a world free from
poverty driving positive change through
the power of entertainment they make
grants to charity partners that support
people living in poverty in America and
in some of the poorest communities in
the world since they first set up shop
in 1985 they've been doing three main
things raising millions through two big
fundraising campaigns Red Nose Day in
sports relief spending that money in the
best way possible to tackle the root
causes of poverty and social injustice
and using the power of that brand to
raise awareness of the issues that need
the most attention if you look at their
site in their YouTube channel you can
see all the good people as well as
celebrities who have come together to
raise awareness of the good you can do
and usually in the most memorable of
ways check them out and see how you can
donate to a cause that can bring a smile
to anyone's face
[Music]